la saison des tornades approche mais il
nous faut plus de chevaux pour ce voyage
long et difficile
ce mustang réussira toujours à nous
échapper c'est petit tonnerre le plus
rapide de tous les muscles
[Musique]
ce que je peux être ton ami
ouais
[Applaudissements]
pour ta générosité yakari et je te
confie un don c'est pas les mal en quoi
mais je peux parler à tous les animaux
et plus rigoureux dans tout ça c'est
qu'ils parlent casta au travail
si je marche comme ça le temps que
j'arrive au barrage
ils auront terminé le travail de titan
mer ça veut dire quoi
c'est le nom que ma tribu les 6 août ont
donné ça vous êtes drôlement à nyon
[Musique]
ag